[Applaus]
[Musik]
es gibt einen bereich in dem china immer
noch nicht mit den vereinigten staaten
kooperieren
ein bereich in dem die usa nach wie vor
unangefochtener weltmarktführer sind
weder china noch japan noch irgend ein
europäisches land können hier auch nur
im entferntesten den usa das wasser
reichen
die rede ist von universität
denn egal welches ranking man sich
ansieht überall belegen amerikanische
universitäten so gut wie alle
spitzenklasse ein abschluss aus stanford
oder dem immer die scheint eine sichere
eintrittskarte für die weltweit besten
jobs zu sein und viele von euch denken
jetzt vielleicht dass die amis deswegen
sehr stolz auf ihre universitäten sind
dass alle studierenden dort
überglücklich sein weil sie ja wissen
was für eine blendende zukunft sagt gut
dann sind uns aber mal die folgende
schlagzeile
studierende protestieren gegen erhöhung
der studiengebühren wären universitäten
online gehen welchen groth aber haben
diese hyper privilegierten studierenden
überhaupt so aufzumucken hat es etwas
mit dem corona dies zu tun sind sie
dermaßen endlich darauf zum
frontalunterricht zurückzukehren
ganz und gar nicht die amerikanischen
universitäten mögen großartig sein aber
sie haben ein großes problem
parente studiengebühren in den letzten
jahrzehnten sind die college preise in
den usa in die höhe geschossen
die höhe der studiengebühren hat sich
innerhalb der letzten 30 jahre mehr als
verdreifacht und eine vorstellung zu
geben
ein studium in harvard oder yale kann
mehr als 50.000 dollar pro jahr kosten
wie soll man das aber alles bezahlen
können ich bin sicher viele von euch
kennen die antwort bereits mit
studienkrediten in den usa müssen sich
zwei von drei studierenden verschulden
sie sich ihre ausbildung überhaupt
leisten zu können
und mittlerweile sind die ausbildungs
schulden von 45 millionen amerikanern
auf anderthalb millionen dollar
angestiegen
ich wiederhole billionen also 1500
milliarden gut einige von euch wissen
jetzt vielleicht nicht wie sie diese
summe eigentlich einordnen soll
ist das tier oder erledigt nun ich kann
euch versichern es ist sehr viel es ist
mehr als das bruttoinlandsprodukt des
landes wie spanien oder anders
ausgedrückt es gibt nur zwölf länder auf
der welt die es schaffen würden in einem
jahr genug zu produzieren um die vom us
college studentin angehäuften schulden
zu begleichen
das ist besonders schmerzhaft im
vergleich zu europa wurde studium in den
meisten ländern für studierende
kostenlos ist das problem die
studiengebühren ist so gewaltig dass es
eine politische priorität wurde einige
demokratische kandidaten der letzten
präsidentschaftswahl habe vorschläge wie
diese gemacht us-senator dick sein das
schlägt einen gesetzesentwurf für
gebührenfreie colitis und ein ende der
studien schulden vor
die goldwaage hinter alldem lautet also
warum sind unis und college in den usa
überhaupt es so verdammt teuer
was sind die unterschiede zwischen dem
amerikanischen und dem europäischen
modell heute werden alle diese fragen
natürlich beantworten und zwar wie immer
mit einem kurzen blick auf die
geschichte die bildung der mittelklasse
bis zum zweiten weltkrieg waren
universitäten den eliten vorbehalten
doch während des krieges ändert er sich
als präsident roosevelt wollte dass
seine soldaten eine bessere zukunft
haben nachdem sie in europa und im
pazifik ihr leben riskieren mussten also
verabschiedete er zwei wochen nach der
landung in der normandie den service
managers beträgt das ergebnis dieses
gesetz ist zusammen mit dem
wirtschaftsboom der nachkriegsjahre
machte die vereinigten staaten zum
ersten land der welt in dem die
mittelschicht aufs college gehen konnte
der amerikanische traum materialisierte
man konnte seine kinder aufs college
schicken und bis heute hat jede neue
generation besser leben können als die
ihrer eltern
viele dinge sind sehr erschwinglich
geworden
hightech produkte reisen und
qualitätsmedien die visual politik aber
es stimmt auch dass zwei wichtige dinge
teurer geworden sind wohnen und
universitäten
[Musik]
warum aber sind die studiengebühren so
viel stärker gestiegen als andere dinge
das gesetz von angebot und nachfrage
liefert eine gute erklärung die zahl der
college studenten in den usa hat sich in
50 jahren verdoppelt dabei geht es nicht
nur um us bürger sondern auch um
ausländische studenten denn mehr als
eine million menschen aus aller welt
ziehen jedes jahr in die vereinigten
staaten um dort zu studieren und ihr
denkt er vielleicht aber gibt es denn so
viele junge menschen aus aller welt die
so viel geld haben und auch bereit sind
es zu verpassen nur auf all den
legendären us partys und spring break up
feiern zu können nun obwohl der american
pie faktor nicht zu vernachlässigen ist
denke ich das ist auch andere gute
gründe dafür gilt welche die unsere
amtliche anziehungskraft der
us-universitäten erklärt us hochschulen
belegen acht der zehn spitzenplätze auf
der us liste der besten globalen
universitäten 2020 ja ich weiß was jetzt
sagen werdet baumarkt präsentierst uns
hier eine ranking aus den usa
und das sagt hey leute wir sind die
besten ok absolut faire einwand also
hier habt ihr das ranking der
universität shanghai wir an ein kleines
mädchen mit leichtigkeit erkennen könnt
gibt es keinen zweifel
egal welches rating wir betrachten die
im s universitäten sind die
angesehensten der welt aber natürlich
springt es ab sofort eine neue frage ins
gesicht wie werden diese rankings
überhaupt gemacht kann man wirklich
messen wie gut ein hochschullehrer
unterrichtet messen die da einfach die
zahl bestandener prüfungen oder was nun
passt auf denn hier kommt der
eigentliche knackpunkt der ganzen
angelegenheit die qualität des
unterrichts eines lehrers zu messen ist
schwierig für was es aber quantitative
metriken gibt ist die relevanz eines
wissenschaftlers anhand seiner
publikationen in fachzeitschriften und
die post aus diesem seien andere
wissenschaftler in ihren fünf missionen
zitiert haben was also braucht man an
erster stelle wenn man seine uni in den
rankings hoch rutschen will geld geld um
die besten forschungseinrichtungen
labore und arbeitsbedingungen für
wissenschaft zu finanzieren und damit
dann die besten forscher anzuziehen denn
die gehen nur dorthin wo sie am besten
arbeiten können natürlich am besten
bezahlt werden wo ich eine vorstellung
zu geben
die hälfte des budgets einer universität
die arbeit geht für
hand drauf zu vergleichen
universitätsprofessorin spanien von den
besten fall rund 80.000 dollar im jahr
verdienen in harvard liegt der
durchschnitt bei etwa 200.000 dollar
aber wie wird das alles bezahlt woher
kommt das geld nun dass wir einen kurzen
blick auf diese grafik wie ihr seht sind
der größte batzen 43 millionen spenden
von alois also früheren absolventen
hinzu kommen öffentliche gelder vor
allem staatliche forschungsförderung
wird etwa 17 prozent
und natürlich studiengebühren welche 22
prozent ausmachen
am ende geben die amerikaner 2,7 prozent
ihres bruttoinlandsprodukts für ihre
hochschulen aus das liegt deutlich über
dem oecd-durchschnitt von 1,6 prozent
was bedeutet das alles aber nun vor
allem dass ein guter teil dieses
technologischen wettlauf von den
studierenden selbst finanziert werden
muss und das ist nicht die einzige
schlechte nachricht für sie studiert die
hälfte der arbeitgeber denkt das college
bereite studenten nicht für das
arbeitsleben vor sagt ist ganz einfach
das us-universität modell alle
professoren mehr mit forschung als mit
lehrer beschäftigt sind weil es die
forschung ist durch welche sie prestige
gewinnen und nicht die lehrer aber wie
sieht es eigentlich im vergleich zu
europa aus schauen wir uns das ist mal
ganz schnell an
das europäische modell
der hauptunterschied zwischen den usa
den europäischen hochschul modell ist
dass die besten unis europa staatlich
sind das studieren ist dort meist auch
nicht ganz kostenlos aber im vergleich
zu den spaß uns in den vereinigten
staaten ein absolutes schnäppchen und ja
ihr habt richtig gehört in den usa gibt
es auch staatliche hochschulen aber der
preisunterschied ist trotzdem immer die
niedrigste studiengebühren an einer
staatlichen us universität liegen bei
mehr als 8000 dollar pro jahr
die spanier zum beispiel zahlt man an
einer staatlichen universität in
katalonien höchstens 2800 dollar wobei
ich hier wirklich die billigste
amerikanische klitsche mit der teuersten
europäischen luxus uni verglichen habe
diese unterschiede sind hauptsächlich
auf zwei faktoren zurückzuführen
der erste ist dass in europa der staat
jedes jahr etwa 80 prozent der kosten
seine universitäten trägt und zwar für
alle studierenden egal ob sie ausreichen
oder armen familien kommen
der zweite faktor ist dass die forschung
nicht zu stark immer betont wird wie in
den usa in europa wird also im
verhältnis etwas mehr wert auf die lehre
gelegt aber auch europäische private
universitäten sind viel günstiger als
ihre us pendants die durchschnittlichen
studiengebühren an harvard yale oder den
die in wie erwähnt bei 50.000 dollar im
jahr während die teuersten
studiengebühren an der privaten
universität von navarra in spanien und
18.000 dollar betragen
und das ist natürlich der größte vorteil
des europäischen modells
denn in europa ist einfach nicht üblich
dass menschen sich über alle ohren
verschulden nur um eine anständige
ausbildung zu bekommen was aber opfert
europa für seine günstigen
studienmöglichkeiten nur der
universitäten stecken weniger in die
forschung und sind daher für
hochqualifizierte wissenschaftler
weniger attraktiv denn die wollen ja an
der spitze des fortschritts arbeiten
statt den erstsemestern von denen
sowieso die meisten abbrechen werden
jedes jahr denselben stoff vorzug und
daher muss man um in den globalen
rankings auf die erste eu nie zu stoßen
bis auf platz 26 runtergehen
da sehen wir dann eine dänische
universität und danach sage wieder
nichts dann auf platz 37 eine
französische und auf platz 47 dann auch
eine deutsche um auch mal auf eine
spanische oder italienische universität
zu stoßen müssen wir uns besser unter
die 150 durchkämpfen und wenn man sieht
wo europas universitäten in den globalen
rankings stehen versteht man ein wenig
warum die europäische kommission dann zu
solchen skurril anmutende
verzweiflungstaten greift die eu plant
europäischen rivalen zu google mit neuen
vorschlägen für daten und technologie
denn europäische forschungsprojekt
leiden chronisch an sehr schwacher
finanzierung
europa hat ein sehr soziales bezahlbares
universität modellen aber mit dieser art
von modell ist ist nicht in der lage
technologie giganten apple google oder
tesla zu erschaffen ja noch nicht mal
einen wie das chinesische tencent das
ideal wäre ein universität wien
erforscht aber trotzdem für jeden
geldbeutel erschwinglich ist welches
modell aber ist in der welt eigentlich
vorherrschend und was noch wichtiger ist
ist es möglich das beste aus beiden
welten zu vereinen nun genau das werden
wir uns jetzt mal anschauen
zwei konkurrierende modelle
[Musik]
ich weiß dass ich viele von euch an
dieser stelle fragen lohnt es sich
wirklich so viel geld für eine
hochschulausbildung auszugeben wie in
den usa ist ein studium an der
universität wirklich eine garantie für
einen guten job
nur wenn wir uns die puren daten ansehen
lautet die antwort ganz eindeutig es
kommt darauf an zunächst einmal brechen
30 prozent der studenten ihr studium
ohne abschluss ab aber bedeutet dies
dass die all die studiengebühren ganz
umsonst bezahlt haben nun wenn wir in
veralteten kategorien der titel
gläubigkeit denken ja den führenden
fortschrittlichen unternehmen ist dies
aber ziemlich schnuppe
für manche abbrecher war das ganze also
eine fehlinvestition anderer konnten
aber vielleicht auch ohne papier in der
hand eine menge bisschen aufsaugen
erfahrungen und collection sammeln und
diese dann in bare münze verwandeln
und was ist mit jenen die es bis zum
schluss an der uni aushalten nun es
kommt auf die art des abschlusses an und
die universität ein software ingenieur
wird nun mal nicht dasselbe verdienen
wie eine absolventin kurzgeschichte und
ein absolvent aus yale verdient nicht
dasselbe wie ein absolvent der
universität von nevada
das durchschnittliche gehalt zehn jahre
daran abschluss aus harvard liegt
zwischen 80 und 90 tausend dollar an
anderen privatuniversitäten liegt das
durchschnittsgehalt jedoch bei etwa
40.000 dollar
und das ist etwa das gleiche was man
auch als absolvent einer staatlichen uni
verdienen würde die aber viel billiger
ist mit anderen worten die entscheidung
für ein college bedeutet nicht nur dass
sich viele studenten verschulden sie ist
auch mit einem großen risiken verbunden
die berufsaussichten und schwanken sehr
stark je nachdem für welche hochschule
man sich entscheidet was also schlagen
politiker wie bernie sanders vor um
dieses problem zu lösen ganz einfach
mehr staatsknete
mit anderen worten würden sich denn das
bild das der staat für alle neuen
studiengebühren und alle studenten
schulden aufkommt die reden hier von 2,2
billionen dollar über einen zeitraum von
zehn jahren oder dann würde der
steuerzahler neue studiengebühren in
höhe von weiteren 48 milliarden dollar
pro jahr übernehmen müssen und das alles
mal in die richtige perspektive zu
rücken
wir reden hier über ausgaben die den
kosten der ausrichtung von drei
olympischen spielen entsprechen aber pro
jahr ihres ja ja ja ja
und wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt sieht
es im augenblick nicht so aus als ob die
muss einer der zeit in der sie bereits
ein haufen geld für die schäden der
kroner maßnahmen ausgeben müssen noch so
viel kohle für ihre studenten übrig
hätten wird es also auf absehbare zeit
gar keine staatlichen hilfen für die
armen studierende immerhin die zukunft
der nation geben doch die gibt es
bereits zwar keine direkte hilfe ist in
staatliche darlehen zu sehr niedrigen
zinssätzen also im grunde so was die
basel wo ich eine vorstellung zu geben
92 prozent aller studien schulden über
die wir gesprochen haben sind bereits da
allein aus washington eine der am
häufigsten verwendeten formel heißt bmw
i
wenn man das konto verlässt stadt hat
man das darlehen in form von zehn
prozent seines gehalts an den start up
und was man erschafft dadurch alle seine
studien darlehen zu tilgen ist das
tollste was man jedoch nicht genug
verdient um alles innerhalb von 20
jahren zurückzahlen
er lässt einen der staat den heißt acht
millionen amerikaner nehmen an diesem
programm teil klingt doch gar nicht mal
so unfair oder worüber beschweren sie
sich dann also noch nun genau darüber
dass diese art von buy liste zu einem
weiteren anstieg der studiengebühren
beigetragen haben da hast du denn durch
dieses programm einen leichteren zugang
zu einem günstigen krieg bekommen somit
also solventer sind verlieren die
universitäten jegliche skrupel ihre
studiengebühren in astronomische höhen
zu treiben
sie saugen also automatisch jegliche
mittel die der staat zuschießt sofort
für sich ab mit anderen worten es
scheint keine perfekte lösung für dieses
problem zu geben
und hinzu kommt noch etwas was wir
nämlich mit aller gewissheit sagen
können ist wenn es ein modell gibt das
sich in der welt immer mehr durchsetzt
dann ist es genau dieses us modell so
hat saudi arabien etwa zehn milliarden
dollar in den aufbau einer universität
nach us-vorbild investiert wenn katar
sein universitätssystem ankurbeln will
kopiert ist nicht einfach nur das
us-modell nein sie transportieren es
direkt zu sich in katar ist ein uk bauen
us college ist eine akademische oase
georgetown und schwestern sind einige
der universitäten welche ihren eigenen
cottbus in katar betreiben die er
verfügt über eine niederlassung in
singapur die new york university in
shanghai und ab
mit anderen worten es
dass sich die welt wird teure
studiengebühren im tausch gegen
spitzenforschung entschieden hat denn
sie alle haben eines ganz sicher
begriffen
das ist direkt im valley würde oder die
stanford university nicht existieren und
das gleiche gilt für viele andere
bereiche will die usa in so vielen
technologien führen sind dann vor allem
deshalb weil sie in der lage waren
forschung zu finanzieren an ihren unis
mit anderen worten die us universität
hat bewiesen dass sie der beste ort ist
und ergebnisse wissenschaftlicher
forschung zu liefern
die frage ist nun aber ob sie wirklich
der beste ort ist um zu lernen anders
gefragt wird es in zukunft noch so
wichtig sein ein universitätsabschluss
zu haben und einen guten job zu bekommen
das aber mein leben zuschauer wird ein
thema für ein anderes video
denn genau diese debatte wird in den
kommenden jahren immer stärker geführt
werden und wir werden immer mehr
nachrichten wie die folge wir zu sehen
bekommen
google apple und zwölf weitere
unternehmen verlangen von ihren
mitarbeitern keinen hochschulabschluss
mehr
haltet also die augen auf und schreibt
uns eure meinung in die kommentare
denkt ihr dass ich deswegen das
hochschul modell ändern wird und europa
den usa und generell glaubt ihr dass
sich unsere kinder werden verschulden
müssen um ihre ausbildung zu bezahlen
oder werden sie an einen selbst
vielleicht einen abschluss direkt von
google bekommen ich hoffe dass euch
dieses video gefallen hat war sagt uns
wird ein teil des mit euren freunden und
vergesst nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren
machs gut und bis bald
[Musik]